hi my name is alex and this is my recipe
for cinnamon roll apple pie
so this video is actually my third video
i ever made for tasty i made this pie
for tasty for the holiday season and it
was such a smash hit that i to this day
still make it for my family during the
holidays too so one day i was thinking
about cinnamon rolls i was thinking
about apple pie and then
i just figure
why not have both
porque
the visual you get once you bake this
pie is insane but let me tell you the
flavors are also really classic so i
decided to make a classic apple pie and
then utilize the cinnamon rolls for the
apple pie crust so i remember the
testing process of this pie was pretty
tricky but the end result is so
delicious i promise so the filling i use
for this is pretty classic and simple of
course we added some sugar and cinnamon
in there and the cornstarch is there to
help thicken up the filling don't skip
it because then you'll have a watery pie
and no one
wants that
i prefer to use fresh apples in my apple
pies but feel free to switch up the
filling if you like you can cook down
your apples you can use macerated apples
anything you want you do have to cut the
cinnamon rolls in half because you want
them to be small enough to form the
beautiful oily crust my biggest piece of
advice for this is to use a serrated
knife because that will just make your
life so much easier so to simplify this
recipe we ended up using canned cinnamon
rolls because it just is so much easier
and a quicker process to get the crust
that you want when i was originally
testing this recipe i wasn't sure
whether i wanted to use pie dough or to
just use cinnamon rolls i decided to go
the cinnamon rolls because it really
gave you that beautiful swirly visual
because if a cinnamon roll apple pie
doesn't have swirly cinnamon rolls then
is it really a cinnamon roll apple pie
probably not
[Music]
and one more big tip do not forget to
put the foil on top when you first bake
the pie
this will ensure that the inside of the
pie bakes fully before the outside crust
burns don't skip it don't skip it don't
skip it don't skip it don't skip it
no you won't forget i hope
another reason i wanted to use the
canned cinnamon rolls is because they
all come with this delicious icing that
everybody knows from their childhood it
just takes it to the next level so the
reason i love making this pie for my own
thanksgiving is because it is such
a showstopper everyone is so impressed
when you put it down on the table it's
so beautiful they wonder what's inside
that feeling never goes away and it's
not only so pretty it's also so
delicious because you get cinnamon rolls
and an apple pie in one kill two birds
with one pot it seems like a lot of my
videos are taking familiar flavors and
then revamping them with a new twist on
a crust i think that's because the crust
is a great outward visual representation
of the recipe it's not always what's on
the inside that counts
i know
i
i know i'm not that shallow guys it is
what's on the inside that counts but
just for cinnamon roll apple pie it's
what is on the outside that counts i
hope you make this pie it was a
swirl
cinnamon
and
spices pie
i like pie
all right just make it
don't forget the foil
[Music]
[Music]
you